hi everybody brian anderson
capital ones the match is back the
fourth version
of the match and what a match it's going
to be we're going to be
in big sky montana moonlight basin and
it happens july
6th so aaron rodgers is new to the game
he and bryson d shambo
are going to take on past champions of
the match
that would be phil mickelson and that
would be tom brady and let's start
with our latest pga championship winner
the oldest major championship winner in
the history of golf phil mickelson at
age 50
for all of us enjoying our 50s like i am
phil that was one of the greatest things
i've ever seen
i'm so proud of you i was so happy to
watch that and see you succeed
um what's going through your mind still
a few weeks after that incredible
victory
it's been a lot of fun obviously and
i've been
inspired by my partner in the past and
seeing the work ethic that he puts in
and the ability to be at his best
at an age when nobody thinks that he's
able to and and it's very inspiring and
i've had a lot of fun and
i'm very excited to partner with him
again because the more i'm around him he
brings out the best of me brings out the
best in those
around him we have two awesome players
to compete against and i i know what a
good golfer aaron rodgers is i've seen
him swing a club
he's got a natural smooth swing and
creates a lot of speed
as does his partner they're going to be
a great fit because they both
hit bombs and at altitude it's going to
be a tough task
however tom and i we have some
unfinished business
well tom after the last match and uh you
know you're you're in the rain
and it was it was a it was messy you had
the big moment though you hold out
and now you're back on the match we
missed you by the way at the last match
the match three but you were off going
on to win super bowls and whatnot uh
tell us about the super bowl victory
tell us about
how you feel you know i mean you're one
of these old guys too that continues
uh to keep shining here give us some
thoughts on what what you've been up to
since we saw you last at the match
yeah i'm definitely getting older i
think the oldest guy in the league i
think i'm older than most of the
uh not only players but nfl stadiums at
this point i've been around so long so
except lambo that one's been around
quite a while they've added
some things to that but i've actually um
had a good off-season
um i had knee surgery so that's just an
excuse and put one of those on the board
in case it doesn't go well
but uh working on this golf game here in
the upcoming uh
you know about less than a month that we
have
and uh my partner is going to help me
with some chipping and putting i know
that
uh based on the format i think there'll
be a lot of that for me
so he'll be getting us off the tee and
uh it should be a really great match it
should be
we got two incredible competitors i know
aaron i've played
on the field obviously an mvp season as
a player but
uh very talented golfer bryson and
everything i've watched him do and
really admire his game
i've only played aaron one time we
played at riviera
played a nine-hole match uh i will say
he made a very clutch
putt on the ninth hole to beat me uh
still very disappoint but that so
there's a chance for redemption
of course which i mean i'm prepared to
do very nice well let's go from one
quarterback to the other aaron rodgers
the reigning mvp of the nfl erin
some hawaiian resort set up there it
looks like
you're having a great time you've really
kept a low profile
this offseason i've hardly seen your
name at all you haven't
hosted any tv shows or been in and
involved in any kind of controversy or
anything
it's been a nice peaceful offseason for
you it sounds like ar
it's been yeah thank you ba it's been
one of those quiet off seasons you just
dream about where
you can just kind of go through your
process on your own quietly and
um you know that's all you can ask for
as an older player in the league and
somebody's been around for a long time
and just
enjoys that time to yourself just relax
to not be bothered to not have any
obligations or anything going on
you know i think that's what this off
season's been about it's been about
really enjoying my time and
spending it where i want to spend it and
not feeling like i have to go anywhere
not having any responsibilities but
still being an nfl player
at the same time it's been great well
let's bring in bryson d chambeau and now
it's your first match bryson and you are
the reigning us open champion
i mean you've been involved in some
pretty good golf events but
i don't know this one's right up there
man there's a lot of people watching i'm
sure you're feeling the pressure already
no no well it's got to be the top of the
list for sure it's uh first off an
extreme honor to be playing with
you know go to the game and i'll
definitely say this that
uh phil you know you did win the pga man
but i mean this this last tournament you
played in at colonial
didn't go so hot so you know i only go
off of like what you've previously done
like the most recent
victories that you've had and then
obviously the most recent losses you've
had
that's the way i play the game you know
if i if i don't play play very well i
finished 18th you know this last week
i'm only as good as that so you know
phil i don't know about that game
that you got but it's okay you know
we're gonna see how it works and
tom obviously tremendous respect for you
there's no issues whatsoever but
dude i just can't wait to be testing
those golf balls out you know those
things may feel a little different when
it comes game time but
we'll see we'll make sure that that
stuff's uh all dialed in and make sure
it's all conforming
but uh no i'm certainly excited for for
this whole match it's going to be
unbelievable the charitable
charitable aspect is incredible and you
know when it comes down to it we're
aaron and i are gamers we're in there to
win and we don't want to lose and
uh it's certainly going to be fun
hitting some bombs out there i i can't
wait for it it's going to be amazing
bryson if i could just add that i
understand why you would not want to
add up victories from past performances
and
based solely on today and what happened
in the last week i totally get that
i mean tom's got i don't even know how
many super bowls to count why would you
want to add them all
up you want to go off the most super
bowl recent super bowl winner well
happens to be him too i understand why
you wouldn't want to add up
45 tour events it could be daunting or
six majors that would be
daunting hard to overcome i get it so
you go just go off the most
recent major winner no yeah i mean i i
get it you got you got 23 years on me so
that's okay
that's true that's true i like it i like
that bryson was a little whining about
the uh
the trash talk at least in football we
can trash talk without calling in the
commissioner
which i know i read something today he's
looking for a little uh
political help along the lines of the
pga tour but that's totally fine we
don't
football is a little different sport
phil if you could activate
something what would you be activating
for the match for so
i'm i'm going to try to activate a lot
of things
obviously obviously the cavs i want to
activate my voice because
i feel like there's a highway
into their dome and i want to get on
that highway
and i don't care how we win yeah if we
have to like just get them uncomfortable
and settle a little bit like i'm willing
to do that this is the format to do that
now i want you to know
we're not having fans it's not because
of bryson but it's
we just didn't want to have an issue so
yeah
so we're we're not going to have fans
there so there'll be no people there
there'll be no
spectators hecklers and that's coming
from like
the commissioner of the match like we're
not gonna have fans
no i you know i appreciate that my
concern though was actually for me to be
hitting
it so far that i was flying greens and
hitting people over the greens you know
that was honestly my concern that's why
i really did it and wanted to be
you know cautious of the people around
and make sure there's nothing going
wrong
um so i appreciate your understanding
but i'm more looking out for the humans
in general around the area i really
don't want to be
uh you know hitting it too far and
hitting people and whatnot because
that's something that you honestly have
a problem with i know that you spray it
quite a bit
um right see i didn't want spectators
there because i was worried about
hurting them left and right you were
worried about long and short i thought
sure dude yeah where was that player
the players number four like did you top
one
i don't know who even who even knows
well i was trying to get a better angle
into that green actually i just felt
like
you know hidden down the fairway wasn't
that great of an option but
um no you know i get it i mean sometimes
you know things work out for people and
sometimes they don't but
you know at the end of the day i'm
really trying to make sure that there's
a
a good understanding that you know i'm
doing it to protect
you and me so this is a you know
one-on-one thing and
and for tom as well i really don't want
to leave him out of the question because
i i know he wasn't hitting it great last
time
annie ripped his pants so there was some
definitely some some things
leaking in that match but that's okay i
i'm sensing aaron
some some qb huddle leadership going on
with you and bryson bryson's coming out
hot tom came out hot
on social you've been kind of laying low
though laying in the weeds though
i'd like to get some perspective from
you aaron about
how you're going to go about this thing
if you wouldn't mind sharing i know it's
it's risky to share with your opponents
listening but
anything you'd be willing to share well
they're a little older so they're
probably not paying much attention um
but i just want to stir bryson up that's
the one thing i feel like that i was
brought to this match added late
probably third third alternate to just
stir
bryson up and get him going you know i
mean once he's going
he's the tasmanian devil i mean he
anything in his way and i don't care if
it's
phil or tom or phil brings brooks to
caddy whatever they try and do to get
under our skin
i mean if i can just get bryson going
get him pumped up
um i feel like it's an easy win for us
tommy you know like i got nothing but
love for tom so i'm i'm gonna be nice to
him
if i could do anything in this match
like if when i think about it lay my
head down my pillow at night and think
about what do i want to accomplish
i'd love to get under phil's skin i
don't think it's that hard
that's something that i would just love
to do to get him
so domed up whether he's looking at my
right calf
i used to have two great cats i pulled
my left one really bad so it doesn't
really
have the same type of definition anymore
but he's looking at my right calf
with just the most insane jealousy of
a true calf-like adonis and that kind of
gets it going maybe it's in the range
uh you know or maybe he sees my long
sleeve
collared shirts a la phil 2010 and goes
damn
that's a great look something that kind
of just
just irks them a little bit maybe i walk
right next to them the entire time
um you actually have me you actually
have me thinking about
two calves and being unequal and out of
balance like how
how do you do that like if you try to go
onto your left calf
and you can't really like and you go you
push hard off your right wouldn't you
like
push every shot do you miss it right
like i miss it left
i miss it left a lot but that's not
really because of the cavs like do you
miss it right because of your lack of a
lot of that
because that big old banana you got that
little banana
yeah um phil i
have the strength in the calf but the
aesthetic beauty of it is not what it
used to be
because you know when you play a sport
we actually put your body in the line
week after week
you're prone to having haven't have any
injuries you know we're not
you know sitting in golf carts i know
you've been playing on the champions
tour a little bit
uh you know you're riding around on a
golf cart uh
you know you you're you don't really
have to
do anything athletic the entire day
aaron's got a great point at foot
i think you know golf's amazing
obviously it's a great hobby
uh for us and us football players
you know at halftime we get checked for
concussions you know
at the ninth whole we get to eat
hamburgers and golf so i actually really
enjoy
coming i don't mean to cut you off there
because go ahead and
when's the last time you had a hamburger
i mean let's let's keep it real good
point everyone
it's been a while well said what do you
guys know about the golf course
by the way i mean he's got some
elevation i think i think everybody here
is going to be hitting
lots of bombs on this golf course yes no
that's i don't think so i think it's
only going to be me
i'm in a world of my own in that regard
that's true
that's kind of true actually yeah that
that actually is true
that's not shade that's just facts just
facts bryson
i mean when you're swinging the golf
club at 145 miles an hour it's kind of
not a competition at that point
actually this course was specifically
chosen once we had our opponents
because it's at elevation and it is so
much more difficult to
judge the distance when you're hitting
it as far as pricing hits it
that he's right long will be an issue
you don't want to have spectators short
maybe unlikely but getting the right
distance control at elevation when
you're hitting it that
high far and hard it's almost impossible
so it gives
such a distinct edge and that's kind of
what we were going for well it was
exactly what we were going for
big sky is an amazing place they got a
lot of great golf courses up there
uh i played a lot of golf up there never
at moonlight basin which i hear is an
incredibly difficult course so
um i think the pro golfers will have a
great
uh competition i think aaron and i will
be
doing our part and uh like i said i know
aaron's
very clutch and i've seen it firsthand
i think bryson is obviously um very
sensitive
uh but a terrific player i think he
might drive that
777 yard pro 5 on the 17th
uh which will be the longest drive in
pga tour history
and if he doesn't i'll be disappointed
so we'll see what he's got
i mean with all those muscles it should
go somewhere
he wasn't a golfer he'd be like a
division three linebacker or something
like that
you know at the end of the day you can
you can say all you want but aaron and i
are grinders and competitors and
you know just like you all are our golf
games are a little bit better so
yeah we'll see we'll see i do think you
do have a partner that
would probably have liked to go for it a
little more often than he has in the
past so bryce i'm glad you're
encouraging
him to to kind of go for it when it's on
the line so rather than
you know just not getting the fairway or
something like that and try to try to
play for the next shot
yeah i i'll never i'll never push anyone
to do anything so he can choose whatever
he wants to do
i well i usually don't get the option in
my that's what
i know the pain there's two aspects i'd
love all you guys to talk about real
quick
number one is there's a charitable
aspect always involved in the match and
it's it's been
great we've raised a ton of money um
throughout the history of the match
but also you guys are all wearing
microphones and earpieces
so you guys are familiar with being
mic'd up but the earpiece
brings a new piece to the puzzle where
you can interact with each other and
people get to see
you guys interact in a way they feel
like they're in your foursome
which i think is really unique about the
match and bryce let's start with you
because you're new into this
but you know give us your thoughts on
participating in this event
some of the charitable aspects are going
to be a part of the event and then
competing with not only a microphone but
an earpiece
yeah i think one of the most important
things we could ever do is is get back
to charity and and be doing this for
charity um
it's something that you know i am
extremely passionate about i have my own
foundation as well as
everybody else here has their own
foundations and i think that as we look
at it as
professional athletes we have to be
giving back to others that are
less fortunate than us and and it's
something that
you know if this wasn't if the
charitable aspect wasn't a part of this
i probably wouldn't be doing it
um you know because i care so much about
it uh having an earpiece in
i think is gonna be awesome because
people finally get to hear
and see what i'm saying essentially um
you know that they're going to hear
everything and you know get to go what
the hell is he saying
finally so that'll be fun let's go to
you next aaron
uh just same question your thoughts
about competing
the charitable aspect but also having
you you and tom
actually probably more savvy than most
in this kind of event because you're
constantly listening in your helmet uh
you have an earpiece you know but
there's going to be some distraction
there don't you think yeah probably
depending on
i'm not maybe as soft and i'll put tommy
in this category as well like having
somebody
talk in our ear it's kind of old you
know we've been around been there done
that so having
that constant chatter probably won't be
that big of a deal golfers are always
you know worried about where somebody's
standing or
you know somebody's saying something a
murmur in the crowd i mean that's
that's that's a lot and i've played at
pebble before i've actually
you know played behind phil that was
like a six-hour round because
um before bryce i think phil was one of
the slower players on tour
um no offense partner um but uh take the
time
the match as long as you want but uh but
yeah the terrible aspect is great i've
been working with a great organization
in northern california called the north
valley community foundation and
um the north as as tommy knows
you know northern california has been
hit by some tough times last
three years three four years five years
has been some really really
devastating fires including one that was
really close to my hometown of chico
so i started working with them really
extensively after that
and obviously with the pandemic
small businesses especially have been
hammered
across the country so i started a
separate to kind of side fund under the
nvcf umbrella to help with uh
with small businesses and in my the
county i grew up in so it's it's fun to
keep working with them they're great
people
there's a lot of people who are hurting
up there and it's fun to be able to help
them out
and and also you know be able to compete
that's great aaron how about you tom
yeah absolutely and you know i think
about what we did last year
and raising i don't know tens millions
of dollars for
feeding america you know at a time of
the pandemic
you know and over the years i think as a
professional athlete you're able to
impact people in so many ways just
outside of entertaining people for a few
hours
on the weekend so you know whether it
was make-a-wish foundation i've been
involved
for 20 years with the great organization
called best buddies
which helps promote friendship between
mentors and those with intellectual and
developmental disabilities
um there's just a lot of things to do
and as we all know there's always people
that can use a little bit of help in
different ways and everyone has
different cause of it so many teammates
involved um
i have my own foundation uh tb12 sports
um you know giving treatment to kids who
who normally wouldn't be able to receive
those types of things in order to
maximize their abilities
so all of it is very gratifying and as
much as
winning games on the field you want to
win off the field as well
and giving back to those in need is the
best way to do it and i know
this is another great opportunity to do
it and create great awareness through
through all the different you know
amazing guys on this zoom right now that
have done just that for a long period of
time
yeah very well said tom how about you
phil give you last word on this
i love the way the match has brought
together some of the best in what they
do and we've got
two of the best and greatest of all time
in the nfl
and you get to see as a fan aside of
them it's a little bit different it
shows a more intimate side of them their
sense of humor how fun they are
and i i love the way that's come out in
the last three
and i'm excited about the way it's going
to come out and people see
what a good guy bryson is and how uh fun
and
athletic and and capable and so many
things
aaron rodgers is and so i love the way
the match has done that
and also creating opportunities for so
many others and i know that
when i was eight years old and my
parents took me down to the local
uh public course to try to get a job and
give me an opportunity to play in
practice because we couldn't join a club
uh there was a there was a pro there
that took a risk
on hiring an eight-year-old so that i
could go pick the range and have an
opportunity to play in practice there
and if i didn't have
somebody like that take a risk and give
me an opportunity i wouldn't be
playing and doing what i playing golf
for a living and doing what i love and
so
creating opportunities is what i've
always believed in and i am so proud of
the opportunities
that this match has provided so many
while
also showcasing a side of these great
athletes that doesn't always
get shown while they play their sport we
hope to have some great memories with
you guys at the mats for
big sky montana moonlight basin
thanks so much